I have a mom hack that will change your life literally
hi I'm Chelsea
a 31 year old homeschool mom
and if you're anything like me
you prepare a lot of snacks and meals for your kids
our day starts with breakfast
then second breakfast and then a snack lunch
five more snacks dinner
another snack and then a bedtime snack
does that sound familiar if so
you need to start making snack boards
it's basically a charcuterie board filled with fruits
veggies and your kid's favourite snacks
you serve it at lunch and let it sit on the counter until dinner
instead of asking for snacks right after lunch or while you're cooking
they can help themselves to whatever is left on the snackboard
since I started doing these
my kids no longer ask me for snacks
and they have increased the amount of fruits and veggies they eat
throughout the day it is a win win in my book
I switch up what I put on the board each day so they don't get bored of it
and I let them pick out what they want from the grocery store
so they're guaranteed to eat it
there's also a great way to cut back on food waste